on this day January seventh in 1789 the
electors for the first presidential
election in American history were
selected we all know who won that first
election and all of George Washington's
fellow founding fathers knew who was
going to win the reason Washington was
first in the hearts of his countrymen
was that he put those countrymen his
fellow citizens and his country first
Washington said the Constitution is the
guide which I never will abandon it was
for that reason that he is properly
esteemed for who he is George Washington
understood what we today too often
forget that the federal government must
be responsible to the American people
not for them it must protect our liberty
it must do so Washington knew by
protecting us against external threats
and insofar as we enfeeble our nation's
ability to ensure our country's security
we endanger our Liberty by limiting
government size and reach citizens help
to ensure that it will do the things
that it must do that is why we have
titled today's talk it's not just the
economy stupid our speaker today Brian
Kennedy understands the threats that our
nation faces today mr. Kennedy is
president of the Claremont Institute its
mission is to restore the principles of
the American Founding to their rightful
preeminent authority in our national
life president of Claremont Institute's
excellent quarterly publication the
Claremont Review of Books mr. kennedy
also is director of the Institute's
ballistic missile defense project he has
written widely on national security
issues in the Wall Street Journal
National Review and investors business
daily among other publications he also
sits on the independent working group on
missile defense Brian Kennedy is spoken
for Hillsdale College on many occasions
were pleased to welcome him today for
the first time to Washington DC please
join me in welcoming Brian Kennedy thank
you David for that very kind
introduction well good afternoon
everyone thank you for having me here
today it's a great honor to be here for
Hillsdale College I i share with
Hillsdale students something something
important I like them are a student of
Hillsdale president Larry yarn who has
been a friend and colleague of mine for
20 years he hired me 20 years ago at the
Claremont Institute and i'm proud to say
the same thing of doug jeffrey who many
of you know who is in the back of the
room there doug is the quiet and
indispensable intellectual behind the
best parts of the conservative movement
whether it's been at hillsdale college
or at the Claremont Institute thank you
Doug for having me well as was said by
David I have the pleasure of serving as
president of the Claremont Institute our
mission is to make these first
principles you hear so much about these
days these first principles of the
American Founding preeminent again in
our Pollock politics to make them matter
not just to say them but to make them a
reality as a practical matter my
colleagues and I remind alert and
otherwise explain to the most important
Americans including all of you that
their freedom can be lost that the
prosperity and domestic tranquility our
country enjoys can all be taken away did
that in the great history of the world
no country like ours last forever and
certainly not a democratic republic like
ours lost because we have enemies who
would like to see our way of life
destroyed because it is we Americans
that represent freedom in the modern
world now on the airplane here from
California I said next to a very fine
chap a Christian minister who was coming
here to Washington I asked him what he
was going to be doing while he was here
spreading the good news of Jesus he
he asked what I was going to be doing I
told him spreading the bad news of Brian
because i think our situation today is
much more serious than our elected
leaders would let us believe Abraham
Lincoln called us the last best hope of
Earth we are that to be sure but we as a
people don't always appreciate this we
are a blessed people blessed to be here
in North America protected by two oceans
and with neighbors in Canada and Mexico
that we have been very careful to
cultivate these past 200 years some of
us like those in this room are aware
that we have permanent enemies enemies
that are capable more capable than ever
of seeing us destroyed well I'd like to
begin with the question indeed the only
question we should be asking when it
comes to our national defense can
America and the free world actually be
destroyed do we have threats to our very
existence that even in these tough
economic times when we're so worried
about how to create jobs must we not
also worried about our national defense
we are told that we are the most
powerful military in the world and that
we will have no serious challenge for
some time to come and we are comforted
with three reassurances meant to end
serious discussion about national
security policy you know these
reassurance as well they are first that
Islam is a religion of peace second that
we will never go to war with China
because our economic interests are so
intertwined and third and perhaps the
most controversial that America won the
Cold War and that Russia is no longer
our enemy now these myths are propagated
on the left and right and we would like
to believe them because to believe
otherwise would suggest we have enemies
who seek our destruction our
marginalization or our subjugation now
let me stay transparently the
unfashionable thing and say we in fact
do have enemies in the Islamic world in
Russia and in communist China they
operate abroad
and here in the United States you will
know from reading Aristotle and your own
common sense that everything is done for
a purpose in world politics states often
do what is in their interest when they
go through elaborate planning spend
enormous treasure requisition men and
materials and organize them for a
purpose then we know that statecraft is
at work today we must understand who our
enemies are and take the necessary steps
to defend these United States or we will
suffer the consequences these
consequences may be the end of the
American Way of life constitutional
government or the very lives of the
American people it would much it would
be much easier to tell you all to go and
listen to your iPods or go on facebook
and go shopping or watch 300 channels of
cable TV I can't that wouldn't be right
you all in this room are too important
for that you have a responsibility to
know better to do something about it due
to do something before it is too late
that is the way of a Hillsdale student
that is the way of others in this room
that have made it their business to work
to defend this country and its
principles now let me address three
areas of confusion in our current
understanding of our national defense
these are as I say the Islamic threat
Communist China and Russia first Islam
is a religion of peace we were told this
after the attacks of September 11th
after Islamic operatives hijacked and
flew planes into the World Trade Center
the Pentagon and were thwarted before
hitting another target here in
Washington probably not very far from
here now President Bush was a very good
man and he believed or was otherwise
persuaded that Islam was no different
than a strain of the judeo-christian
heritage that its adherents the Islamic
adherence were peaceful decent people
who abhorred what happened September
11th president bush even said on october
eleventh two thousand two that islam is
a vibrant faith millions of our fellow
citizens are muslim we respect the faith
we
honor its traditions our enemy does not
our enemy doesn't follow the great
traditions of Islam they've hijacked a
great religion and quote now in this
very partisan town it's common to circle
the wagons and support the president
when he is thought to have conservative
leanings and even today since we know
the President Bush was such an otherwise
decent man but mr. Bush and his
administration did the country a great
disservice by saying that Islam was a
religion of peace for it was trying to
understand them as we would like them to
be rather than how they in fact are
although Islam is organizationally built
around a belief in God whom they call
Allah Islam is more properly for the
purposes of our discussion a political
ideology organized around the Quran and
the teachings of its founder Muhammad
its teachings allow for the subjugation
1.3 billion people who like most people
are inclined to believe there is a God
and that his prophets have spoken to man
but whereas Christianity asked asks its
adherence to render unto Caesar what is
Caesar's and to render unto God what is
God's islam teaches that the Quran is
the absolute Word of God not subject to
interpretation that to disagree with the
6,000 odd verses of the Quran that are
organized into 114 chapters or sarahs or
even reinterpret them is blasphemy
punishable by death Islamic authorities
of all the major schools of Islam teach
us that the Quran must be read so that
the parts that were written last that
were written last rule over the other
parts they do not come last numerically
in the Quran since it is arranged that
the largest chapters are first and the
smallest chapters are last the so-called
theory of abrogation requires that we
look at the chapters of the Quran which
were written after Muhammad went to
Medina and 622 ad for guidance so
although there may be peaceful parts of
the Quran they do not guide what an
adherent Muslim ought to believe
now this isn't often done especially
here in Washington let us look at then
at those chapters of the Quran written
last sir as nine and sir as five sir 09
holds quote fight and slay the
unbelievers wherever you find them and
lie in wait for them in every stratagem
of war but if they repent and establish
regular prayers and practice regular
charity then open the way for them for
Allah is oft-forgiving most merciful
that is sir a 9 verse 5 another verse
fight those who believe not in Allah nor
the last day nor hold that forbidden
which have been forbidden by allah and
his apostle nor acknowledged the
religion of truth even if they are of
the 40 people of the book until they pay
the jizya with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued sir a 9 verse 29
let me repeat that earlier one fight and
slay the unbelievers wherever you find
them and lie and wait for them in every
stratagem of war sir 5 o ye who believe
take not the Jews and the Christians for
your friends and protectors they are but
friends and protectors to each other and
he amongst you that turns to them for
friendship is of them verily Allah
guideth not the unjust that is sir 5
verse 51 now these are the most i would
say radical violent parts of the quran
it is often said that anyone who picks
out these who cherry-picks these as it
were is picking them simply to
demonstrate that the Quran is violent
and that this is somehow unfair but I
would offer that we must understand
Muslims as they understand themselves
they believe that the infidel the
non-believer is to be made into a Muslim
or be killed or to be subjugated by
conceding sovereign Authority and paying
the jizya or tax to that end they can
lie to the infidel under the principle
of takia that they should not be friends
with him x
deception and that they can kill the
infidel this is not by the way one man's
interpretation this exists in the book
the Quran not subject to interpretation
except by punishment of death if a
muslim says otherwise it is for all
practical purposes a live meant to
deceive us for is not our job to
interpret Islam in ways that would make
us feel better our job is to defend
these United States from all enemies
foreign and domestic our job is to
understand them again as they understand
themselves and it not matters not
whether the number of Muslims who
actually believe this is a thousand or a
million or 1.3 billion we know it is
believed by adherence to Islam who have
taken up arms against the United States
who have operated as terrorists and who
control regimes abroad who are either
sponsoring terrorism against the United
States like Saudi Arabia or building
nuclear ballistic missiles such as Iran
it is the doctrine of our enemy who is
making war against us both here at home
and abroad in this country they take the
form of the Muslim Brotherhood and their
organization alarms such as the Council
on american-islamic relations these
Islamic Society of North America the
Muslim student associations and others
their job is to persuade American elites
that Islam is a religion of peace
documents obtained at the Holy Land
trial in 2007 in Texas that investigated
terrorist funding including the
following include the following from the
Muslim Brotherhood strategic memorandum
on North American affairs they actually
did a memorandum internally so that they
understand internally what they're doing
they say in their internal memorandum
the general strategic goal of the groove
in America this is this is straight from
their document the general strategical
the group in America which was approved
by the Shura Council in the
organizational conference for the year
nineteen eighty seven
quote in able meant of Islam in North
America meaning establishing an
effective and stable Islamic movement
led by the Muslim Brotherhood which
adopts Muslim causes domestically and
globally and which works to expand the
observant Muslim base aims at unifying
and directing Muslims efforts presents
Islam as a civilization alternative and
supports the global Islamic state
wherever it is having established
established its leadership the
memorandum States at the role of the
Muslim Brotherhood in North America they
continue to say the process of
settlement is civilization jihadist
process with all the means Thea Quan
meaning the Muslim Brotherhood they say
must understand that their work in
America is a kind of grand jihad in
eliminating and destroying the Western
civilization from within and sabotaging
it's miserable house by their hands and
by the hands of the believers so that it
is eliminated and Allah's religion is
made victorious over all other religions
again this is coming from their document
they say without this level of
understanding that their goal is the
establishment of Islam here in North
America without this level of
understanding we are not up to this
challenge and have not prepared
ourselves for jihad yet it is a Muslims
destiny to perform jihad and work
wherever he is and wherever he lands
until the final hour comes and there is
not escape from that destiny except for
those who choose to slack but with the
slackers and the Mujahideen be equal end
of quote again if one were to ask the
average Muslim if they know any of this
the answer would be no of course not
indeed very few would understand in the
Muslim community the Quran with any
level of detail but what matters is that
this is what the members of the Muslim
Brotherhood in the United States and
within the Islamic world that are
violent this is what they believe they
who live in the United States in
believe this and they operate an
influence operation here in the United
States to have us believe that Islam is
a religion of peace we of course have
evidence not that I even need to mention
it of the first bombing of the world
trade center the attacks on September 11
and isolated tax most recently at Fort
Hood and elsewhere more than anything
else because we're a free society and
illiberal people in the best sense of
that word more than anything else this
notion that Islam is a religion of peace
has cowed American policymakers to
believing that Islam is a religion to be
treated like any other religion indeed
to mention the threat of Islam as Islam
is in any kind of serious way is to be
labeled a bigot or a racist some of the
groundbreaking work done on the threat
of Islam was by MIT by major Stephen
Coghlan who while working as a lawyer
for the Joint Staff and the Pentagon
tried to explain the ideological and
practical threat Islam posed to the
United States this work led ultimately
to the recent book Sharia the threat to
America that was co-authored by mr.
Coughlin along with Frank Gaffney andrew
mccarthy Jim Woolsey and other members
of the national security community I'd
recommend that book to you in it we
describe the threat that Islam presents
to a free society since we do not want
to see our fellow countrymen as
potential enemies of the state we
Americans don't think that way we don't
want to think that way the part of our
problem is that we really don't know how
many Muslims there are in the United
States we don't know how big a problem
this actually is and to suggest that
there may be a security threat raises
these species charges of bigotry because
it matters at some level just how many
Muslims there are during the Bush
administration they used the number
about 2.5 million Muslims the Pew
Research Center in 2007 estimated there
were two point three five million
Muslims in the United States
the Council on american-islamic
relations cair put the number at five
million Muslims in two thousand
President Obama in his Cairo speech in
June of 2009 put the number at seven
million so there's quite a quite a bit
of discrepancy there other people I know
think the number could be as highness
nine million the pew research center
again which did that that lower number
did a survey of opinions of Muslims in
2007 and they found a couple of
interesting responses and again I say
this not to vilify any Muslim I say that
simply to understand them as they're
trying to understand themselves and that
we can look with clarity moral clarity
at who they are and how we can live
together eight percent of American
Muslims again American Muslims said that
suicide bombing eight percent of the
Muslims said the suicide bombing can
sometimes be justified in defense of
Islam and the simple map if we take a
number such as seven million that mr.
Obama said that would be 560,000 people
who live in the United States believe
suicide bombing can be justified among
Muslims aged 18 to 29 fifteen percent
believe that suicide bombing could be
justified and among this age group sixty
percent thought of themselves first as
Muslim and second as American and among
all ages in that 2007 survey five
percent had a favorable view of al-qaeda
now that we have not suffered another
large-scale attack after September 11th
is due in part to some fine work by law
enforcement but more likely the
inability of the Muslim Brotherhood to
capitalize on what they've built and
there is I will say the great
uncertainty as to how Americans would
react widespread terrorism within the
American heartland Americans may be a
very genteel people but also a people
whose passion for freedom could lead
them to drastic measures and i believe
the muslim brotherhood doesn't quite
know how we would react in the meantime
this still
jihad that is going on presents a threat
to the United States that lingers just
below the surface of public debate and
one that presents a unique challenge to
both law enforcement throughout this
country and to the US intelligent
elegance community it's one thing to
have hundreds of individuals to deal
with what if that number is thousands or
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands of citizens whose allegiance
is not to the United States but to an
operational form of Islam that seeks the
destruction of the United States we
don't like to think in those terms it
will divide us society create animosity
among citizens and SAP us of our focus
against equally dangerous threats
because whereas the Islamic threat here
at home which is yet to be fully
realized presents great danger it is
only one of other threats including the
Islamic threat which is in fact
existential in nature from Iran the
Islamic Republic of Iran so moving away
from America to our threats abroad today
in Iran they enrich uranium that they
will convert to plutonium which they
will use in a nuclear warhead someday
the Iranians we think of them as as
backwards at times they're not they have
advanced ballistic missiles such as the
shahab-3 that they can launch from the
land or from a ship off of our coast the
Iranians the Islamic Republic of Iran
possesses missiles that can destroy an
American city or if they were able to
deliver deliver the warhead as an
electromagnetic pulse weapon they will
destroy the electronic infrastructure of
the United States that could result in
the deaths of hundreds of millions of
Americans again this is from a country
that believes it must destroy the
infidel with every strategy of war we do
not yet today have a missile defense to
defend these United States from this
ship launched attack or from an attack
from China
in Russia so they say their purpose is
to destroy us with every stratagem of
war they build ballistic missiles and
what do we do in return how can we
thought to be serious about our national
defense we Americans when we will not
defend us from such a ship launched
attack or from a nuclear attack by the
Chinese or the Russians this is in part
because not merely do we misunderstand
Islam we seem no longer to understand
superpower conflicts consider here China
we trade with China and they buy our
debt indeed they have two trillion in
u.s. reserves about 1.1 trillion of
which is in us treasuries their
economies and ours are intimately
intertwined they would never go to war
with us it is thought because that would
be to destroy their main export market
and despite their intense desire to
reunify with the free people of Taiwan
who they consider a renegade province it
is said that the Chinese will never
fight Chinese but they are building an
advanced army navy air force and
space-based capability to limit the
United States and our ability to project
power in Asia the Chinese today have 2
million men under arms and although
their Navy and Air Force is not as
sophisticated as the United States or
Russia they still possess an untold
number of ICBMs most of which are aimed
at the United States and hundreds of
short and medium-range missiles for use
in an Asian theater of combat Chinese
military thinking is openly
anti-american in their military journals
they write openly about such strategies
as unrestricted warfare using a
combination of traditional military
means along with cyber warfare economic
warfare atomic warfare and terrorism
this is what they write in their
military journals they're also working
develop a space-based military
capability they are investing in various
launch vehicles including manned space
flight a space station an extensive
anti-satellite weaponry meant to negate
the United States cool
mobile satellite coverage they like
Russia will do everything in their power
to discourage the United States from
deploying things such as missile
defenses that could stop the Chinese
nuclear capability and the ability of
China to operate at will in the Pacific
absent a missile defense that we
currently do not possess that can stop
Chinese ballistic missiles the US will
be hard-pressed to maintain security
commitments in Asia given the advances
China has made to its offensive nuclear
forces the u.s. 7th fleet however
capable cannot withstand the kind of
nuclear missiles and nuclear tipped
cruise missiles that China could employ
against it the destructive capability of
the Chinese df-21d against our aircraft
carriers can raise the stakes of a
conflict in the South China Sea that
would not port pretend well for the
United States the Chinese have studied
American capabilities for the past 20
years and have built offensive weapons
meant to negate our previous advantages
whether or not these Chinese advances
are indeed effective is unknown but what
we do know is that the United States has
not taken in my view adequate steps to
modernize our forces to meet the
ballistic and cruise missile threats of
our enemies the SS and 22 cruise missile
called sunburn cruise missile which was
designed by the Russians and deployed by
the Chinese and Iranians presents a
technological challenge because of its
Mach 3 speed and enormous size these are
physical problems in time and space that
very smart people try to figure out and
do something about the Chinese the
Russians the Iranians they have thought
about these problems they have tried to
solve these problems to their advantage
now that's at the level of capability
what of intent China has for some time
carry out carried out a policy of what
has been turned termed the peaceful rise
of China they possess a growing economy
and a growing military power but with no
clear intent of being an aggressive
power that's what we've seen so far but
what we've seen lately is the rise of
what scholar
such as tongue been have turned termed
the Red Guard generation these are the
generals that are about 50 to 65 years
old who grew up during the Cultural
Revolution and who are now taking the
reins of the Chinese military they are
no longer interested in communist China
being a secondary power in the eyes of
the world and they believe themselves
that they can match their economic power
with military assertiveness now this can
manifests itself by a desire to take
back taiwan by force avenge themselves
of the wrongs done them by Imperial
Japan or remove the United States as the
preeminent military power in the world
however far-fetched this may seem to the
American policy maker sitting not very
far from here it is widely held that
America is a superpower on the decline
with economic problems that will limit
our ability to modernize our military
and maintain our alliances around the
world one can see in the Washington Post
today talk of cutting back our defense
procurements and because America lacks
adequate conventional military means to
wage war against the country as large as
China it is thought the US would have to
resort to full-scale nuclear war to
defend its Asian allies from an attack
by China this is a prospect that caused
mouths a tongue to turn the United
States a paper tiger that although we
possess economic and military power we
will not use them to our advantage now
this may only have been propaganda and
I'm not saying I believe that but
current Chinese aggression against Japan
and the senkaku islands in the East
China Sea and they're open assistance of
the Iranian nuclear program as well as
sale of arms to the Taliban in
Afghanistan by the Chinese would suggest
that the Communist Chinese seek to
marginalize the United States and to
play the role that the Soviet Union once
played as sponsor of global revolution
against the West which brings us finally
to Russia and the degradation of
strategic thinking
after the Cold War and in this age of
nuclear weapons we used to be guided by
the principle that the central strategic
objective of the United States is the
prevention of direct attack upon the
United States that was simple and
straightforward for the past 50 years
we've been taught something different
that great power politics is beyond the
grasp of ordinary policymakers or even
generals that we must understand the
balance of power between nations such as
the United States and Russia especially
since we possess nuclear ballistic
missiles that America cannot seek
superiority over another other nations
less we create strategic instability
that is the common view expounded by
universities think tanks and schools of
Foreign Service there is the collective
view and I exaggerate only slightly that
America is hardly worth defending or
anyway that American military power is
fundamentally suspect and far from a
fringe point of view these people occupy
the foreign policy and national security
establishment of this country but you
will say these are the intellectual
shortcomings of the left perhaps
conservatives for their part have been
basking in the glow of winning the Cold
War a war I will say not to be one so
mentally invested in the victory
conservatives fail to appreciate that we
did not disarm the Russians of their
nuclear arsenal we did not stop there
active measures to undermine America in
the West nor did we create a liberal
democracy in Russia what then was
winning the Cold War all about and why
should it be celebrated so constantly
for the past two decades we paid the
Russians to dismantle nuclear warheads
they would have dismantled anyway all
the while they use those resources to
modernize their ballistic missile
arsenal we on the other hand we
Americans have not tested a nuclear
warhead since 1992 so to be clear we
don't even know exactly if they work we
have no more tactical nuclear weapons
thinking the superpower conflict or even
any serious
Challenge would not come to the United
States nor did we build the missile
defense promised by Ronald Reagan since
this was no longer necessary since of
course we won the Cold War instead we
prefer to stay vulnerable to our enemies
when we know we have the ability to
prevent their nuclear arsenals from
destroying or keeping us hostage this
was true under Republican and Democratic
administrations alike including the last
one why does missile defense matter you
ask it seems like a specialty issue
doesn't it kind of like the national
security equivalent of the flat tax but
of course it is not merely a specialty
issue it is the singular issue upon
which our national security must hinge
because so long as the Russians possess
offensive weapons that can destroy us we
must substantially accede to their
demands less we escalate tensions to
full-scale thermal nuclear war which I
hasten to add we will not do it is said
that every war is a moral struggle moral
and that involves life and death the
forceful requisition of many materials
used to wage war and ultimately victory
or defeat and although the Cold War is
said to have been won by the West it was
not so much a victory as an interlude
and we would do well to get on with the
crisis at hand for instance the Senate
just ratified the New START treaty that
will reduce our nuclear arsenal and will
likely cause us to further delay the
building of missile defense because now
to build missile defense would be
somehow to sour our relations with the
Russians perhaps the question ought to
be asked what is the morality of signing
a treaty with a nation such as Russia
that engages in massive deception
against the United States supports our
enemies abroad and builds ever more
advanced nuclear weapons whose purpose
is the blackmail or destruction of the
United States the debate over the New
START treaty might have been easier if
it were merely deficiencies in the
language restrictions on missile defense
and the unverifiable ax t of nuclear
inspections something more insidious is
at work as the desire to ratify new
dart reveals both the moral bankruptcy
of a foreign policy establishment of
this country and an extraordinary amount
of self-deception by the people who know
better at the heart of our strategic
defense today is the notion that we will
use massive nuclear retaliation against
nuclear power that attacked us but
absent the reliability of our nuclear
arsenal and a smaller nuclear arsenal
how can such a strategy work today we
possess an aging nuclear force that we
are not really sure will work if we had
to use it to retaliate to Russian
Chinese Iranian North Korean or an
undetermined rogue attack so perilous is
this lack of modernization of our
current nuclear arsenal that the Obama
administration believed it could induce
senator jon kyl into leading the charge
for approval of new start senator Kyl
thankfully knew better and did his best
to stop it new start just so that we're
clear about this will not modernize a
single warhead within our arsenal but
will instead create the illusion that
America is better defended after all is
that not the point why does one not make
a treaty so that they're better off
after the treaty the question of nuclear
modernization of our Arsenal should be
to Barrett should be debated hearing
should be held about on it and we should
look at the condition of our nuclear
force and take whatever steps are
necessary to ensure our nuclear
deterrent the second it's not at all
clear that fewer weapons will make us
safer as strategists have often warned
fewer nuclear weapons is likely to
encourage other nations to build nuclear
weapons themselves rather than to
discourage them catching up to the
United States is a powerful incentive if
one wants to dictate world affairs to
their liking third the Russians make
this treaty because they do not engage
in a single act a foreign policy without
consideration of what will give them a
global advantage over the United States
and its allies in the West new start is
no different the Russians today wish us
to reduce our nuclear arsenal and to
forego miss
defense they on the other hand are
modernizing their forces and possess
themselves a crude system of missile
defense using surface-to-air missiles
with nuclear tipped interceptors we have
no way of knowing today how advanced the
Russian offensive force is and has
become or how detailed their missile
defenses have evolved to but even in
well-meaning policy circles Russia is
thought not to be an adversary even The
Wall Street Journal says Russia is not
an adversary Russia wanted that treaty
because it gives them strategic
advantage and the United States today
will not even contemplate building
missile defenses to stop a Russian or
Chinese nuclear missile aimed at the
United States the argument is made that
limiting our nuclear arsenal and not
developing new and better nuclear
weapons gives us the moral high ground
in dealing with other nations really can
a nation like ours be said to have
nuclear superiority when in fact we
won't do the most basic constitutional
duty and provide for the common defense
of our people by building a robust
missile defense missile defense has
referred to these days as if we already
have one and I'll say this again we
cannot stop a single russian or chinese
ballistic missile nor are we planning to
build a system that will stop a Russian
or Chinese missile this is a fact
unknown to many Americans and unspoken
by many American policymakers for fear
of the rightful anger it would engender
in American citizens if there is any
more profound moral statement a
country's willing to make than that they
willingly knowingly and purposely keep
their citizenry vulnerable to enemy
missile attack because of the morally
corrupt notion that is better to engage
in full-scale nuclear war rather than
build a defense against such weapons
let me say in conclusion that if we're
not going to defend the American people
from these many threats we ought to tell
them that is the candor do of free
people now what I said sounded like bad
news I don't mean it to be because if
the American people actually understand
these facts if their elected
representatives actually tell them these
facts I think I think they will demand
something be done and something be done
quickly we have the technology to build
missile defenses to stop an Iranian
ballistic missile a North Korean
ballistic missile which we can somewhat
today and we have the technology to
build missile defenses against Russia
and China today we don't do that there's
something unconscionable about that
which if explain to the American people
I believe they will rise up in anger an
anger that will rival the Tea Party
anger over the mismanagement of our
economy and Obamacare and other problems
today so I want to thank you for
listening to all that and I'd be happy
to take your questions
yes sir
what do you think they're in game for
the United States 10 years from now
maybe 15 years
well thank you thank you for that
question and I agree with your son Islam
is a a real danger as I've tried to
explain the political left in America I
think doesn't worry about national
security because they think the
political right is worrying about
national security and an unfortunate
thing is that the Democrats in this
country used to concern themselves with
national security they were
anti-communist and unfortunately they
moved away from that to purely social
issues and I think they believe that
Republicans when there's really a crisis
we'll figure out what weapon system to
build or or something else I myself
believe that my remarks were not aimed
at them I don't expect them to do these
hard things but I do expect Republicans
to take this seriously and there's a lot
to worry about the title of the panel
was about the you know it's not just the
economy and I think we mean to say to
two Republicans but an two Democrats but
Republicans especially this is something
to be worried about we want to create
jobs absolutely but we also must provide
for the common defense that is among the
first requirements and a time will come
in my judgment where you will have a
Chinese general who wants to do
something because he's tired of being
thought of as secondary and he will have
ambition if there's one thing we've
learned that men desire glory whether
that happens in the boardroom or
elsewhere could happen in the war room
is there a Chinese general who thinks of
putting China on top of the world are
there people sitting in rooms like this
in Beijing or Moscow or Tehran or
Damascus we're figuring out how do we
make our power the preeminent power we
on the right need to take that seriously
because I think they're taking that that
seriously yes sir
yup the microphones coming over here
well thank you for mentioning the Monroe
Doctrine that's a John Quincy Adams
would be proud the that is a violation
of the Monroe Doctrine Hugo Chavez and
the Venezuelans should not be allowed to
make treaties with powers outside of our
hemisphere to build weapons aimed at the
United States it is a sign as I say of
our moral bankruptcy that no one even
raises the notion of the monroe doctrine
that no one would seriously say that's
not going to happen say it publicly say
it to the American people much of our
much of our diplomacy is that done in
private after WikiLeaks I'm not sure how
much of it but um it's worth telling the
American people things with candor on
the economy if we're bankrupt tell them
that we can't afford certain things tell
them that if we have enemies tell them
that yes the Monroe Doctrine don't let
people in our hemisphere that seems to
be an outrage where are the people the
question about the left I expect no one
on the left to say that where are the
people on the right saying what you just
said excellent point yes sir
that's an excellent question the
question really is one can take a
nuclear missile launch it in the high
atmosphere say 300 kilometers above the
earth and create an electromagnetic
pulse in the vacuum of space there's no
fireball explosion that like there would
be in the lower atmosphere it's just a
pulse but this pulse destroys all
electronics by destroying the
Transformers that distribute power
through the United States so if an
electromagnetic pulse bomb went off say
over Chicago and line of sight covered
the entire United States the
Transformers are all destroyed and a lot
of simple wiring is destroyed your cell
phone Mac might turn on but the lights
in this building go out right the
elevators won't work your car may or may
not work you're walking home today when
you get home your refrigerator won't be
working you won't have water because the
water is pumped electronically you have
enough food and water for about three
days in your house if you're like the
typical American after that you run out
of food the stores run out of food after
about three days or a week the
electromagnetic pulse Commission the
Commission convened by Congress thought
that the industrial infrastructure of
the United States absent electricity can
support life here for about 30 million
people we're a country of over 300 what
happens to those other people they don't
have food or water it's a horrible
weapon this electromagnetic pulse weapon
it was thought during the Cold War that
we would do that to the Russians and the
Russians
do that to us today the Iranians are
building nuclear weapons they have
practiced twice in the Caspian Sea
launching a ballistic missile from a
ship so the Iranians practicing in the
Caspian Sea launching a ballistic
missile from a ship a ship which someday
could be off of our coast when they
practice this in the Caspian Sea the
missile was not used to go up and then
re-enter the atmosphere to simulate a
nuclear warhead the dummy warhead was
exploded in the high atmosphere to
simulate an electromagnetic pulse bomb
so it's not a secret the Iranians are
practicing this now in the face of this
two things can happen you can either
build a missile defense that would stop
such a weapon or you could harden the
system I would advocate that you should
do both you could build a robust missile
defense because you will defend us from
not merely the Iranians but you will
defend us from the Russians and the
Chinese in the North Koreans or anyone
else but also heart in the system
because given just natural solar
occurrences we make there may come a
time when we need just technologically a
more robust electronic system that's a
very good question and it seems like
just such a common sense I tell this too
many Americans some of these things and
they all look at me as if I'm the master
of the bleeding obvious right it seems
like such common sense that if you have
enemies practicing to destroy you why
wouldn't you figure out ways of
preventing that because we have an
alternative by the way if we know that
the Iranians did that to us if it
actually happened we would have 200
million Americans dead potentially we
would have the option of then trying to
obliterate 75 million Iranians what good
would that do what comfort would that
give your starving child none build a
robust missile defense we have it within
our budget to do as broke as the United
States is today we can afford that the
technological advances we would achieve
just by doing that the technological
advances our economy enjoys today
were much because of the aerospace
program of the 1960s and 70s this would
actually be a program that would employ
people and defend the United States yes
sir yeah the question is um during the
clinton ministration we transferred a
lot of technology from American
Aerospace to the Chinese and it did
improve their ability to both
miniaturize their nuclear warheads and
it improved their guidance systems the
combination of those things puts our
fleet at risk in the South China Sea
should we try to project power there
with smaller warheads and better
guidance systems one can one can find on
the water aircraft carriers and battle
groups and those aircraft carriers and
battle groups have some missile defenses
but not adequate and these advanced
Chinese missiles both nuclear ballistic
missiles but also nuclear-tipped cruise
missiles that they're able to use with
that technology have made the Chinese
into a very formidable force I don't
mean to paint the United States as
backwards or incapable it's just that
we've not kept up with some of their
developments we can catch up by the way
that should be our business we should
tell Americans as a free people that
they can be defended that they will be
defended that they should be defended
and I believe the American people will
rise to that challenge but the Chinese
are very hardworking they're very
creative and they need to challenge us
in the world yes sir in the back yes you
yeah the Chinese American immigration
and the potential for espionage we live
in a free society I don't expect we keep
many secrets I don't expect us to keep
many secrets I think that's okay I think
it's good to be transparent I think as I
say I think it's good to tell the
American people today they're undefended
because if you tell them they're
undefended they'll demand defense if
America has a strong army navy air force
and missile defense that need not be
kept a secret I don't think there's
anything we can keep secret from our
enemies for instance you live in a free
society they're going to find things out
there's the there's the internet there's
you know WikiLeaks there's there's
always going to be espionage I don't
think it needs to be Chinese Americans
that actually move here to sell our
secrets I think you know any American or
excuse me an American of any race might
sell our secrets people people will do
such things in the history of espionage
it's not been so ethnically motivated as
simply there are some people who which
wish to betray the country I think we we
can build the kind of defenses that can
overcome whatever espionage may be waged
against us and I doubt sincerely in our
history we kept very many secrets I
believe the Russians and the Chinese
have always known almost everything we
were trying to do we have a tremendous
capacity for deception but unfortunately
that's mostly self-deception at the
highest levels yes ma'am
you
why the question is why aren't the
generals raising more of a stink about
this that's an excellent question that's
a hard one because you look at these
generals and they put their lives on the
line and they're good men and they're
decent and they've done some great
things for our country but you ask them
some time to think about politics and it
doesn't go so well look at all the
generals that were in favor of the New
START treaty look at the number of
generals who are for a world without
nuclear weapons that just because you're
a general and you put your life on the
line doesn't mean you understand all the
nuances of strategy or that you are
going to be in the business of demanding
these things I think we we give too much
credence I think two generals and two
military experts about such matters that
I think if you ask the average citizen
in Kansas what should be done to defend
him he will tell you whatever is
necessary find out what our enemies are
doing and make sure we can stop that we
send people to Congress to figure these
things out we shouldn't have to ask
generals most of the things I told you
almost everything I told you you can
read in a newspaper some newspaper
somewhere said what I said today it
talked about the Chinese it talked about
their views you can read the Chinese
military journals right you could read
advance about advancements in the
literature and the actual aerospace
literature about Russian missiles you
could find out from Iranians in
congressional hearings what they're
doing on their nuclear programs we know
these things we send people to Congress
to study these things to debate them and
to build defenses for us and so let's
not rely on the generals because I think
everyone I don't think there's any
generals in this room but I think your
own common sense could tell you that we
have enemies and we have to meet those
challenges we have time for one more
question yes sir in the back
we want to be very careful about any
kind of expenditures that are
unnecessary with the Chinese and within
the Pentagon themselves my colleague
mark halperin mentioned recently in the
Wall Street Journal if they're if
there's a if there's a wasteful
expenditure in the Pentagon we should
cut it absolutely on the other hand if
there's something we need we must
absolutely fund that too how much should
we spend on our national defense as a
percentage some people throw around
numbers three percent four percent five
percent six percent what's the number i
would say it could be a hundred percent
it could be whatever it takes to keep us
a free people now it won't have to be a
hundred percent that's ridiculous right
but we should figure out whatever it
takes to make sure that the Russians the
Chinese and the Islamic world believe
that it would be a bad idea to try to
destroy the United States and if we do
that by the way I don't think we'll have
to spend as much that they'll be
discouraged they don't want to fight a
war with the United States that's a bad
idea we simply need to tell the people
of the United States what will be
required for their national defense I
want to thank you for listening to me I
want to thank hillsdale college for
inviting me and there's a lot to do and
I thank you for your attention thanks
you
you